- Il y a un de mes amis qui m'a
dit : "Luc, manque pas
ton coup4 ans,
est loin de regretter
l'acquison vélo
à assistance électrique acheté
il y a un an.
- Si tu veux faire des grandes
"runs", des grandes "rides",
à ce moment-là, des bonnes
tournéesue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.ue.
- C'est grâce à ce vélo qu'il a
pu compléter le tour de l'île
de Montréal sans trop de misère
et il n'est pas le
- Bien là, aujourd'hui,
à l'âge que j'ai... on pédale
forçant. Comme la Berri,
c'est plus facile à monter.
(rire)
- Les vélos électriques
sont plus que jamais au sommet
de leur popularité.,
selon Vélo Québec, le quart
des vélos vendus dans
la province. Ce réparateur rence
du Tour de l'île y observe
s bénéfices.
HUGO PÉTRIN, propriétaire
- Ça permet de rendre le sport
accessible à plus de gens qui
ne sont pas nécessairement aussi
en forme que... que le commun
des mortels. Donc, on peutances.
- Combien est-ce qn est-ce qn ee
pour un bon vélo électrique?
- 2000 à 4000 $, je dirais que
c'est le "range" complet. Il y a
des beauchers,
il y en a des moins dispendieux,
en réparen réparen réparen répa.
- Lui ici, c'est 1200 $.
À 1200 $, ça donne une bonne
"ride".
- Malheureusement,t
tout à l'heure du coût, c'est
le coût qui est trop élevé.
Je suis aussi biene moment-le m,
tu sais, ça va m'être utile
plus tar
(rires)
- Oui, c'est cher à l'achat,
mais au bilise, il n'y a pas
d'essence à payer.
êtes beaux, vous êtes
capables, vous êtes
inarrêtables! mesure que le vélo
électrique gagne du terrain,plut
une opportunité d'en faire
leur principal mode
tout en demeurant actif.
- Bien souvent, je ne l'utilise
c'est quand je suis sur une
pente régulière, le vent dans le
visage, ça me permet d'en faire
plus longtemps.in,
Radio-Canada, M